вид представника володів у нали різанину
оцінки економічних витрат країни через
блокади донбасу під і куди перрі більше
не в 1 годину експерти нога кінь ситуації
для української економіки на прийом на 1
колапсу не буди в витрати ввп лукадо
донбасу volvo та економічне зрощення
заявляти в українській про ряд золотинка
ми міністерство фінансів
про середнє чому річник витрати вид
блокади може 100 ногу це за
песимістичного сценарію до 2 500 до ВВП
але там є для дачі наводить та ще й
шукай цифри за прогнозами dragon capital
витрати вид блокади зупиняти один
обличчя так ввп
експерта в ніч основи кінь до 100
повернися прогнозі
і в тратою бюджету можна оцінити
позбавлена ​​про кінсі руку в трата робочих
місць
блокада завантажувати тисячам робочих місць
вражаючи кілочки голова донецької
облдержадміністрації Сергій Тарута та Ціве
чується в ж за раз від ж примі рівно в
дев'ять кому як сухими та 200 людей вид
провалу спростити банани просіяти його
тримай 2 витрати на відер під нею ще 800
позики хіромант нам роботам і м директор
pet pro ім ства на вимикаючий після них
завершення
ще частий але рубає накида ось цими
правди спростити витрати в енергетиці
блокада матом і на стиль як ратич не
на трохи для енергетики яких годин на
мага і ти смолого то українська влада
пробні мати її голосі ясна може ви на
батіг і
all excel і шиї загальне ряд багатим а
традиційний баланс ресурсів але краще
піти в центрі розумкова українська т
зможе проти таємниця лишачи ногою або
олл-ина газета мазуті бугель не забувши
згуртовують лише область, що теми
потреб країни в електроенергії думав
експерти народити урядів team захир і дата
sean диверсифікації таймер у зображенні
оля дача на коня
блокада донбасу негативна більше
велику причину у витратах українського
бюджету єн його на російська агресія
і в тратил і хитаються та доки он він
перекинеться